so so Lynn and I thought I'd just start
by by it starting with the question that
it's pretty much on everybody's lips
right now what is your theme song and
why my theme song this is used to
these we did this at Draper University
and good this is a stumper I know like
I'm trying to think of like when lots of
all listen to music theme song how about
so something that matters to like I mean
it could be like we are the world right
hurt cuz she'd won best test this I
don't didn't come to me like that I'll
take it okay we'll go with go that um
okay so tell us a little sets a kung fu
fighting oh that feels more like the
theme song is comfy fighting yeah it
feels like it every day come to fight
just go to fight I'm fighting um okay
tell us how underwater hockey is played
eventually we'll find out about solar
city but yeah I'm supporting the exact
letting go so the and so mask funds one
hand and stick and a fox made of lead at
the bottom to pull you play six players
aside in the water you have four subs
the template is a team 15-minute harms
you go down hold your breath play as
long as you can before you run out of
air you give the puck to your buddy you
go up get some air and just alternate
now so sexy naughty a big spectator
sport as you can imagine but it's
tremendous fun factor trying to get
Stanford to to create a team so any plug
you can do to get there are there any
like rules can you dunk can you keep a
guy down yeah no drawing is allowed and
the it sounded like possible where it is
actually no real filing but you do you
can check somebody you can't
you can can be a little fighting but
it's actually a very very friendly spot
it's it's often played coed I'm actually
mainly paid code only at the
international competitions is it played
men and women but mainly at the local
pickups as coeds it's real friendly it's
a if you like swimming this is far
better than swimming swimming you get
tired of that black line for a long time
and and then if you like it what a part
of those the top players that they often
come and play the sport you need a
bottom that's uniform yes it suggested
one c'mon criteria in the flat bottom
and I guess you could play from side to
side you always play over the the width
of a over the whole world it's a width
of Olympic size pool so it's 20 25
meters by by 15 meters is typically the
length and width and feet I forget what
that is that should be a varsity sport
here okay so okay so you are a very
close cousin to elon musk and your
brother also grew up in the family
apparently and and so your mothers were
twins right yeah so what was it in this
family I mean this is amazing what you
guys have accomplished and is it like
did they say Linden you have to save the
world you have to you know with the
world's getting too hot we need solar
energy or did did she just sort of kind
of let you run free and and hopefully
the environmental thing came up way
later I could we were brought up in its
Africa that's like the country still
doesn't be recycling like it's just to
put it in perspective so there's no in
maybe they just starting now but it's
not environmental is not a big focus all
his head wasn't when I when I was
growing up and let that happen is as we
got older and anum not sure if it just
happened that we wanted to solve the
problem but when before Seoul City and
we had a softer business and nothing
wrong soft it great great software
companies out there but when you're in
the grind back to the come through
fighting like every morning you're
waking up and just get into the grind
you just
work work at the end of the day if the
only outcome is is its financial that
gets old and you want something I can
get you more motivated but otherwise you
you don't work as hard you don't push
this off as hard and so finding a job
where you can actually have a financial
reward but also have an environmental
reward or a different award lettuce
something that helps humanity that's
exciting because it you can get up feel
passionate about it and it's a double
one so that's kind of what sledded to it
so yeah you okay so before SolarCity you
ran ever dream okay and ever dreamed
it's other thing you know as a different
business how has how has that affected
SolarCity did you learn something from
everything that made you realize that
you should be doing something a little
different it's so easy yes so one thing
I liked about ever dream it was a okay
outcome and it wasn't a wild success we
ended up starting to Dell computers for
120 million and the internet period we
went through the dot bomb and give chase
reporter is always through by the way
thank you very much that they gave me my
first two million-dollar check when I
was 22 years old and like wow real money
anyway so that started a ever dream but
in that period the the financial crisis
so this is specifically the software
financial crisis in the Bay Area
occurred and it was the the technology
crash and the experience somebody learns
that are facing real real problems makes
you a better athlete like like you just
you you have to work on it you have to
hone your skills better and so I'd say
that that experience helped a lot and in
solo city just we had to solve problems
that we probably have to solve if the
company doesn't have the financial or at
least the the technology crash and then
we grew out of their technology crest
and then ended up selling it to douse so
it was a okay
come and that that I'd say was
invaluable so okay now SolarCity's by
you you install all the panels
everywhere and then and then it
generates energy and that energy goes up
onto the grid and after a while somehow
you end up owning the the whole grid I
mean you end up owning at least all of
the energy that comes off those panels
how does the financial model work yeah
it's so it's when we started the
business the entire market there
specifically the residential market and
the only way you could buy a solar
system is if you bought it so you have
to use at home Johan your own capital to
pay for commodity which heat which is an
operating costs and so so the only
reason for actually doing this is if you
really are like two strong
environmentalists or you you have
disposable cash and you look at the
long-term returns then it's a affair
very investment so since the in the
beginning solo was was a product for for
the rich like you had to have lots of
money to come out with it and at least
it disposable cash to pay for it so we
looked at it instead of care we have to
create a business model which makes it
really easy for people to adopt solar
and the way how people buying energy
today they don't actually go pay for the
power plant they just pay for you know
as you use it and so we created that
model and allowed us to install the
solar system for free so the customer
doesn't pay for the equipment doesn't
pay for the installation but only pays
for the energy and so then as the energy
produces they pay for that and then we
charge less for that energy than they
currently pay from the utility so giving
the trace of paying more for dirty
energy from the utility or less for
clean energy from us and that's it
helped us that's enabled us to grow the
level that we've grown right now we've
made an easy decision for customer to
get clean energy and part of that
part of that differential has come from
some government subsidies that that have
declined a little bit I significantly
what's the what you're thinking on that
where where do those come out over time
what what happens why did they give you
the subsidies in the first place and
then why are they decreasing them and
what do you think is going to happen yes
it's just all energy in the country is
is highly highly subsidized like highly
subsidized and and the subsidies go so
deep you can't even identify the
subsidies like if you asked them please
come up with a list of all the subsidies
they will miss them like kid you not
love like wait yeah as an example
because I said we get that that backdrop
is a passionate point for me in
California you you have to get a
building permit to install a solar
system that permitting process delays
the installation so imagine you have a
highway you've got cars coming in and
all the cars have to stop for a week a
week that's going to cause a serious
backup not only is that the cost of the
installation is cost of throughput of
the business there's few things we don't
need a permit in in the in the state if
you're going to do a small fence around
your ass you don't need a permit if you
get into a small retaining wall you
don't need a permit if you're going to
do a small tool shed you don't need a
permit and if you can do an oil derrick
you don't need well just say if you want
a world dairy and you don't need it so
it's just like that's not an incentive
that doesn't get captured anywhere as an
incentive it's just the way you deploy
all direct and you has a crazy thing if
you want to structure around the world
Eric you don't need a permit for that
either all the fraternity guys are
thinking how do we build a derrick well
no it's like and then no not show this I
saw houses in Malibu massage beautiful
house world Eric not sighs it's like oh
how did that just pop up the building
doesn't know they there you don't have
to ask for a permit that's our crazies
in Texas it's faster to get a permit for
a fracking facility than it is for solar
system for a house well yeah so that was
just my little rampage on on energy
energy incentives so at the start so
loaded get incentives and most of the
states offered rebates the two primary
incentives it's a state incentive and a
federal incentive the state incentives
has helped initiated the market it was
really really important in California
there was a million home solar
initiative that that worked really
really well so quite a million homes but
it got these thought of it and it was a
billion dollar program and the plan with
that program to last for ten years that
only last like six and a half seven
years but the industry did its job so
the industry reduced this cast as the
instead the stadium standard reduced and
now for the last three years there's
been no stadium centers in California
most of the state's for the last three
years haven't had any staging sinners so
the only remaining stagings earth is
incentive right now is the federal tax
credit the federal tax credit has a
thirty percent tax credit for solar
systems and that's going to be expiring
in 2016 for residential owners and for
commercial is going to go from thirty
percent down to ten percent I hope that
doesn't happened will be bad policy if
it does happen but we are preparing for
that it that it actually said it will be
happening it's going to happen is going
to expire you're Oh it'll expire but is
there a possibility the choices do they
renew or get its pull it away so it's
the it's going to expire unless DC makes
a change and the despair amount of
gridlock right now in DC and but but I
think it it will get it in renewed a
gear of a higher probability than not
that it doesn't get renewed but if we
look at the the problem we need to solve
climate change is a real big problem I
got to know how many storms that will
take for us to realize this i don't know
how many fires will take before we
realize this like how
how catastrophic does it have to be
before we go oh we have no choice
but to react I think the signal will be
loud enough right now but it looks like
we have to turn the signal up in folio
so hopefully we don't have to but bad
policy should be not to continuous that
as we have the solution to our you know
the world's biggest problem and if we if
we stop it i think twenty years from
long ago okay we had the solution and we
decided not to fix it because of a text
delta between 30 cent percent and ten
percent that'd be crazy are the two best
solution to do is not to extend the
federal tax credit for solar don't have
it but penalize those who are killing us
who are polluting the atmosphere like
pay for the pollutions very basic if the
pollution was a liquid you'd have to pay
for it because it's an air you don't
have to pay for it so pay for the
pollution and and so there'll be
essentially a tax on on carbon but based
on the political influence definitely
that's a low probability of that that
happening so that can happen then
continue incentivizing those who are
providing energy that is isn't is not a
bad fire so so your your work is two
questions here your work is saving the
planet it's an ambitious goal your work
is saving the planet and Ilan is sort of
helping with us saving the plant but
he's also trying to get us off the
planet which is more important
SDM and in and is there do the curves
somehow eventually flatten out where you
get the global warming and then there's
Solar City and it starts to flatten out
or are you just sort of delaying the
inevitable where we all just fry it form
for those who play a sport do you ever
give up if you like professional sport
doesn't know what the score is you never
give up like you just play all the way
through because things can change in
youth room right now the scoreboard is
pretty bad and but I think we can run
and but back to Tesla soul city and and
occupy Mars and the subsidy or the solar
industry is a direct addressing our
electrical issues so electricity is the
cause for large air pollution in the
country right at parity with
transportation so electric vehicles then
address that so you have to address both
our energy consumption and our
transportation if you really want to
have an impact on climate change and to
be taking it from both angles and then
the jackpot is is Mars but that's more
for still just decimal for like a
catastrophic event now now do you I mean
let's say the whole planet was covered
with solar city panels does that slow
global warming in some way or is it just
a cleaner way it doesn't make it so that
there's less particulate k what's the
science here it's so absolutely it will
have an impact now it'll take a long
time to to undo that you'll stop it from
getting worse and but that this is a 20
30 year in this tube like this is this
big and if it's just the u.s. that still
doesn't solve the problem we have to get
the years we have to get China we have
to get all the big countries and then we
have to start focusing on the developing
countries because a burning a cheap cost
of energy which is cold and so we have
to address it all over the place
but assuming that scenario we've had a
magic one and we can do it right now
what's all the problem I'm today so
here's another question okay have you
thought like is your R&D department
working on something kind of science
fictiony like putting solar panels
outside the atmosphere and in effect
blocking the sun's ray at noon or
something like that where somehow you're
collecting the energy outside the
atmosphere and then beaming it down so
if you think of all in most energy
actually most all the energy we burn
right now that comes comes from the Sun
you use the light hits the plant this is
still but in efficiency just just like
to walk you through the equation of most
of our fossil for you and like it's the
plant the tree gets bigger then
eventually the tree dries then it goes
into the ground for a million years then
we dig it out then we haul it out to a
factory or a plant we burn it that burn
then heats up water creates steam and
makes it to move the turbine to create
lectricity then we hold it literacy all
the way back to your house and and then
you can use it at step one alternative
skip that process put little glass
panels on your roof capture the light
great energy I think that is more
efficient than that other process so so
we'll get there and and the cost curve
has come down significantly set so now
we are more competitive than kerosene
more compared to competitive than diesel
this is what no subsidy at all in the
u.s. be more competitive than most
energy sources and in most states we're
in 18 states today but that is tied to
the it is dependent on the third santosh
credit okay let's switch to your
actually one other comment on the R&D
department yes no no no space thing we
do have an R&D department we've just
announced the most efficient module
Solomon on the world
trivia so that that was a big deal and
job that's nice taking a record from
competitor feels good but the that just
decided station that record will move
around so strophe so you get to keep it
a little while competitor Texas you get
a bad so that it makes us all better so
it's actually it's a good thing and but
in terms of like as we look expanding
internationally we go to many countries
and back to the incentives like I'm from
South Africa and where the fun is prime
minister came to us saying hey you
should use to expand to South Africa now
but okay sounds great the good son
amazing country and what's your cost of
energy under the cost of energy is
around 15 cents a kilowatt hour okay
this it's not bad like I just really
good it's pretty efficient why is it so
low oh no we highly subsidized we would
pay the government pays about half the
cost of energy okay so you're saying
without the government subsidy your coal
generation and your cost of energy would
be roughly 36 yeah I'd be right for your
own thirty cents I guess we need to come
in there and and and compete and so and
help you test yeah absolutely we need
you have a big energy crisis where
blackouts all over the place now you're
great so you painful half of call and
what's your plan for solar oh no we
can't give you anything oh we have to
solve this problem you're subsidizing
that you go to 15 say exactly you could
end up getting paid but it is amazing
how many developing countries out there
whether we're a source of stimulants is
to pay for the electricity which is bad
rather just give it as a as a credit
because it's it artificially holds bad
energy costs low and as that's what
that's we up against and that's what why
yeah so you got to change people's
thinking it have to look at a lot of
things every entrepreneur has to face
that and the entrenched people who are
entrenched are going to clearly fight
that and so you you're going to be
that's it'll be a fun long come to a
fighting for you if it comes to fight so
here or you've got with you said 13,000
employees is that right it's 1414
thousands it's like we had a little few
different you very much a lot of
overhead yeah its revenue generating
yeah really trying to keep overhead flat
we got a cap-and-trade program captain
trades good joining addicts one in
overhead go to trade for somebody so are
they w2 or 1099 s or but all I employees
are WTS yeah full-time employees all
coming for you benefit stock options it
everything so it's like number one ask
them the company's our employees and
really make sure that they have good
wages it's the spirit challenge but
we've successfully managed to pay people
more at the same time reducing costs so
that there was a we're happy about that
incentive plan that we came up with that
enabled that to happen so how do you I
kind of think we you know people
probably ask how do you manage that many
employees but maybe it's how do you
communicate with all those employees how
do you all get that you know whenever
you come up with something new and you
need to pass that on to the thirteen
fourteen thousand people what do you do
to make sure that it penetrates and they
grok it and they're ready to yeah it's
not easy it's a big problem so we've
tried different things the one is to see
me to work right now is every week we we
have what we call SolarCity TV and then
we'll get different people to speak on
the tvs and our show we broadcasted into
the entire company and it's it's a good
participant it shows up so we can track
the amount of people log in on how many
people watch it afterwards and that's a
good way to get information out and then
email it's never that great but but we
do do a fair amount of email so the
emails intense in the company a little
too much but that is a form of
communication and then just making sure
that you you communicate to your
leadership as much as possible so then
they can carry it carry it is there a
feedback loop back to you is there some
way that they they see something out
there in the marketplace they can turn
around and say hey you want to pay
attention to this yes so it gets hot as
the company gets bigger but a culture
that we embrace is a total open
communication anyone anyone since me and
i always respond to the there's a lot
i'll get back to them best to send me
emails on Fridays because that being you
have the best response don't let the
weekend if you send me an email on
Monday he'll have to be a long response
time you may have to wait to the next
Saturday before I get to that one
weekend to my ketchup time on on an
email but D so we're always respond on
that and the you know it's a cube
environment which is coming here and in
the Bay Area and and and make sure you
get out in the field all the time so you
do it all on weekends how your wife
doesn't like that too much so yes the
trick and so I have some of the same
problem is what I just want to the way I
i think i managed to solve this is that
i managed to find my wife and I was
really young I we met when we're 40 nice
try to data for two years he said no but
it's 16 she said she said yes um so
we've been together ever since and got
married at 24 had our first kid at a 30s
so she's my lifetime partner and the
best person in the world but the sector
of that she doesn't know anything better
like hi she has no idea you mean this is
how it works and so then when I find
friends and make sure the friends up
with husband's like me meaning that they
never there they're always working and
so you keep this little box she's
starting to figure out it's not true and
that 80-hour workweeks is is not is not
normal and that the data X or the
husband actually has to be there
sometimes so that the
she's getting getting getting there
we've negotiated a lot of things I'm I'm
a very little guy like alike data I like
to measure things so when there's a
debate about hey you know that the
family enough I go but feels like I'm
being as a family enough no you haven't
and so this this emotional thing we just
have to guess what the right answer is I
can't handle so we actually came down to
a quota 16 hours a week is my quota that
I have to achieve to be with you it's
family I know it sounds rude or really
sleep during so no no it has to be
quality time and so if it's a-so 16
hours you know it is doable so if you if
you do one hour day then weekends okay
if you don't do anything in the week
then you got eight hour days on weekends
with the kids that's a long day I love
my kids to bits by the way no some of
its but yes so that's fantastic but sees
these managing it okay so back to the
business when I when entrepreneurs come
to me and they say hey you know what
should I have to get funding from you
how do I do that I'm always saying well
one of the things I'm always looking for
is how do you get your customers to
become your sales force so what are you
doing to getting your customers to
become your Salesforce how do you get
them out there doing your work for you
yeah that's really good and one-third of
our business comes from our customers
and so that's and so we've essentially
created as an ambassador program so
their referrals from neighbors or
something yes so it's a dual referral if
you if you're a customer and you refer
your neighbor your neighbor gets a
discount and and you get an incentive so
it's if you don't do it that way you
kind of something out your neighbor
because you get an incentive but now the
difference is you hooking up your
neighbor very big difference and so this
is a small small change so hook up your
neighbor and get them a discount and so
that that has worked well and then they
can become ambassadors
even hook up their neighbors too and
ambassador program and sometimes homes
don't qualify so you run across the
house that the orientation of the house
were just too much shading or the roof
is too old or something may be wrong
with the house but the person is
passionate about solar and passion about
trying to help climate change they may
just become an ambassador and we have a
lot of ambassadors aren't even customers
they'd start referring customers to us
so if you guys are the leaders in this
market and but there are still some
competitors that are coming along what
is your competitive advantage and how is
that going to play out in the future and
is it is it easy to jump into your
business or or not and and and then
maybe what might come and hit you from
some other angle where you you get
blindsided like napster did to the music
industry yeah yes so the in terms of
differentiates us is our vertical
integration strategy so from the
beginning we've decided to vertically
integrate now the downside of that is
you have to manage 14,000 people that's
a lot of people and now the upside of
that is you can optimize costs you can
optimize customer experience you can
optimize for product so earlier on we
made the decision to vertically
integrate and so when we looked at our
competitors they were not in order to
get solar somebody else would sell you
the system then another and I would
probably do the installation too but
some other one else would do the
financing in some case you'd have
extreme you'd have somebody sell you the
system another person you'd do the
financing and then another person who'd
do the installation in fact it's still
quite a bit of the market you have three
different companies you're working with
just to get a solar system in your house
and so out of the gate our competition
was ahead of us because they could
leverage other people's infrastructure
and have them do the sale installation
but when you are in a small market like
us that infrastructure
gets depleted like they can't grow more
than those 20 or 30 partners and the
only way they can grow is either they
provide the working capital needed for
those companies to grow or grow the rate
that they can just grow with their own
profit that they make so it's it's just
just won't be able to grow faster and so
out of the gate that model was better at
least it seemed to be better and then we
overtook it at a healthy pace and the
reason being is because we invest in the
infrastructure we can invest in that
warehouse and get it up to the right
capacity because it's our warehouse if
you play that out though won't other
suppliers go oh I see how you do that
I'm going to do that too and then they
start driving the prices down again and
you you've got this big plan and all
these assets you've wasted on this thing
and somebody else is doing a better job
that's right just going to get a better
job you yep just keep pushing are you
thinking you might just keep driving new
technologies keep on driving but it's if
the essence follow remember the the add
our growth and if you fast forward three
years now four years from now our
capacity manufacturing capacity are
going to be one gig and that only maybe
half a third quarter depending what you
look at of our volume so we want the
other ones to get a product as good as
ours if you wanted to come down we want
to push the industry to say that
standard efficiency is not okay but no
one is working on generation to and the
only ones you're working on that our
startup companies you just don't have
the capital and don't have the bank
ability assets so it's like the circular
event that even if they do have amazing
technology to get it to market is near
to impossible kanaba do by the module
because there's no warranty behind it
these days but it's it's nothing and so
you have to get the big manufacturers to
chase this technology and my hope is
that it pushes the other manufacturers
to do it too and now you're
manufacturing these in the United States
mm-hmm so
did you run into any problems or
opportunities or whatever by setting up
a plan in the United States and what
state did you put it in and why yes we
haven't in New York in Buffalo so it's a
million square foot building except a
live camera feed oh it's da being built
it's really cool and the when we
acquired the solar company that and the
Buffalo does a benefit the manufacturing
to make it cold to how cold weather
outside yes yeah not really but the the
whole thing in fact that it is in
Buffalo and lexie Department of one of
the primary reasons is you can use hydro
creating solar modules is energy
intensive so if you can actually use
clean energy to create clean energy
that's better than using dirty an
integer creating energy so are you using
Niagara Falls yeah it's just a little
years yes and so that how what do you
pay per kilowatt hour from we still
negotiating we just standard a rates are
around five cents a kilowatt Wow instead
actually one of the research by the way
said one of the reasons why we may have
a factory in China and one of the
reasons why we didn't do the big factor
in China is that the cost of energy in
China is actually fairly high it's like
15 cents a kilowatt hour and so when you
look at your shipping costs not just
your shipping costs when you ship
equipment you gave your carrying cost of
the imagery on the ocean she got include
that into your working capital costs
combined with the energy cost
logistically the saying that buffler can
be very competitive yeah that's great
Buffalo needs the job so that that was
reason and they were they put they give
you any subsidy to go to they gave us a
good in Santa yeah that's great affair a
fair incentive Buffalo say no it's fair
so I guess we've gone into most of that
are there any other things that you're
thinking about as you pursue as you grow
this business
you what is it going to look like from
15 years from now I always have this 15
year rule for my entrepreneurs with when
they come to me I say is this company
really going to be there in 15 years
when we have self-driving trucks that
take all your wave their robot factories
that take everything too through self
driving trucks that you know construct
your house by itself and no traia yeah
with a 3d printer and all those very
strange interesting things that we're
kind of excited about having happen in
15 years what does SolarCity look like
and how you know how are you going to
make it even cooler than everybody is so
I think the this may have been happen
sooner than 15 years we starting to see
this this this curse is right now most
of the markets were in right now we
compete against the the utility is our
number-one competitor we starting to see
policy shift changes where we're going
to have to customers we're going to have
a the homeowner to which we sell energy
to and then we're going to have the
utility as a customer as well to where
we sell grid related services to so that
that I think is going to change and so
then what's going to happen is the
utility I don't think the eatery's going
to go away anytime soon so utility
provides a good feature the utilities
now going to have access to millions of
salt little power stations across their
grid with the solar generation and the
storage device they can have the
software application which they will
then essentially manage millions of
distributed systems the same way with
Norman manage their own power plant and
they will load balance the grid their
manage the grid and but instead of them
building out the infrastructure
themselves they can use other people's
infrastructure now we've seen this model
happen like salesforce com is probably
known for software as a service and they
kind of in that create the logo around
that no no software and this is
essentially infrastructure as a service
somebody asked is providing the
infrastructure and the till you then we
use that in
structure as a service now why this
policy has to change today the utility
cannot use somebody else's
infrastructure because they don't make
any money like the rule is very clear
you only make money if you pay for the
infrastructure if you don't pay for the
infrastructure so pass through costs so
if we sell it to utility for ten dollars
they can only rate base ten dollars so
they make no money if you create an open
field it'll allow tremendous innovation
into the electrical infrastructure I
don't know what technologies will get
creative but create an open platform say
yes the problem put out the solution
utility subscribes takes that the
winning bid of that solution if utility
would have done it themselves as to say
that project would have cost a million
dollars they put it out and said that
would make ten percent nine million
dollars if they better not new
technology to come out maybe only cost
500,000 it still make ten percent of 500
but this way the Italia has a lower cost
the ratepayer has a lower cost and it
allows for innovation in a market that
has seen almost no innovation like the
best innovation that we have right now
is smart meters and I not that smart but
it's not being used like it's that you
don't have to go and send somebody to
actually measure the meat by the way a
lot of places still have to measure the
mirror and but it has no control
function it just just just SAT there so
you just remote measurement of your
meter like that's it that's the stuff
we've done in like the last 15 years in
not electrical infrastructure then we
can do better than that now could you
could you start to link SolarCity
customers and create your own grid and
would that make any sense we are doing
that so we launched the micro grid
product beginning this year has to start
to take app do really well and why it's
important for my not this is because we
think that's going to be a big market
it's going to be a decent market but we
would assure that this combination of a
distributed solar combined with storage
it actually makes the grid more stable
you actually have a more reliable ready
actually have it far better so we're
going to prove it out and then go back
to the utility and partner with
utilities you look use this use the
software you use this application use
our assets get other people to log on to
to it and and manage your grid more
efficiently it'll be and you really
think it's worth it a bang your head
against that wall that utility wall
rather than just slowly but surely build
your home grid so that we don't really
need them so to the one thing that where
is it that solar doesn't quite generate
enough no we can so one thing that you
need is you need load balancing and only
way you do that is you have to have a
wire from house to house right and then
you need the I mean you could have
batteries to you have the batteries baby
if you have various batteries so if you
have a self-contained unit with no no
access to the grid you have to you have
to design the system for your one day
peak load of the year and so it's a it's
a pretty difficult your oversized in the
system for you use but if you can
connect wires from one house to the next
ask this person is one day peak load
doesn't match this person you can load
balance and that's essentially our
distribution infrastructure that's what
the utility has that's what they provide
the lines coming into our neighborhoods
are ugly we definitely do not want two
of them right and so that's that's the
it's the one place where the monopolies
don't make sense is to only have one set
of lines coming in and so you want to
bang your head against this atom in bang
that what if you did this where you
every time you install in a house the
deal is you also drill underneath and
you drill a wire that goes into every
neighbor's house to the wall and then if
that neighbor signs up you then link and
they're linked and then another neighbor
signs up in they're linked and then just
slowly but surely it just grows out
nobody sees it it's done on the property
and and I love that idea other than the
fact that it's illegal and
wait wait no no you go to the end of the
property Anna oh it's illegal to go to
your the end of your property you you
know i connect to home's electrical
system no I can eat them you're not
allowed to know even if you bite you
created that law even if the property is
your own property you can't connect them
unless you get special approval to do it
but yeah I know it is that that's just
like the utilities have rigged the deal
a lot of cases that is the case so not
not impossible to get a change but that
there will be a big big of you a big
fight and wikis not setting it up this
think the beaming the wires connection
to that moment dear that place like that
yeah yeah I do it on the other side he
only connect them when the law makes it
yeah exactly go get everything right you
get you get the colors of skills with it
all the Lord turns on its go exactly I
like that there we go hopefully they can
change you put in okay I got one more
question you guys I should probably have
the hook eventually but I got one more
question and that is how do investors
values SolarCity what's the nut today
not very well I mean it's today it seems
under bag but but how do they look at it
how did the optimistic investors look at
it and ahead of the pessimistic
investors look at it and wait because
it's as such a complex system yeah a
little loans and then long-term you get
you become a utility you know so the so
the best way to look at it is what value
will be creating every time we deploy a
solar system so when we deploy a solar
system we have to pay back our tax
equity investors we have to pay back our
debt providers so after we paid back
everyone how much how much money is left
for us because the tax equity investors
and our debt providers cover our costs
so we have to pay them all back and when
you do the net present value of that
cash flow that comes to us after we pay
everybody back we make roughly a little
over a dollar or what am at this year at
the forecast that we
in a lost earnings calm was 900 to a
gang of deployment so at a at a buck
that would be roughly making 900 to a
billion dollars a year so that that
would be a pit crew at occur until your
current level is if you like 900 you a
billion dollars of revenue to you know
so it's knit off to all costs so net net
net um no way companies should be worth
12 billion dollar a lot more so the so
then the debate comes in with investors
is okay well it that value is an npv net
value over 30 year period we use a six
percent discount rate and if some
investors may use eight percent discount
rate fly whatever discount rate you want
it's worth a lot more than it is today
and then and I see so that's uh that's a
dollar what now but it happens way later
said yeah you're really getting you're
getting a dollar wat over 30 years so
next we can put on the sort of it we
getting for free photos or whatever 30
years oh yes so it's also the NPV values
roughly your daughter's so it so Daisy
like a hurdle rate of three percent we
used six yeah and and so the you can say
you cannot sensitivity and if you just
look at our current installations so
after dead and everybody else it's
roughly around three billion dollars cut
that's just the assets generating cash
today those are the assets we've
deployed an example or like you use is
we have a case it makes golden eggs if
you just look at the golden eggs that's
three billion dollars currently there is
no value for the gate for the goods and
so what's more valuable to get the thing
that makes the golden eggs or the golden
eggs and this it makes the golden eggs
in case you want it
they're figure it is midterms they're
trying to figure out like so it actually
looks more valuable than the answer is a
B or none of the above it so I think
that makes the thing that makes the
golden eggs golden goose is better so
what's our timing anybody what time is
it okay we got seven more minutes okay
so ya in a second okay so what how do
you think you know you've dealt with
local governments and federal government
and state government you've dealt with
all these governments what do you think
we should do I mean well first do you
think they operate properly and then
second what what needs to happen so
governments vary by state quite a bit I
got to give tremendous credit to to
California I think it's one of the best
governments in the world Governor Brown
is an incredible reader and and is
passionate about apply my chair
challenges that we have so it is good
policies in California they've came up
long-term programs no stops and starts
and as allowed the industry to grow so
back forty percent of the US industry is
in California New York is not
reinventing its whole electrical
infrastructure and it's starting to
deploy that vision I'm describing where
where infrastructure as a service and
you can interact the utilities so that's
going to be analysis so governor cuomo's
is a another strong leader in this area
a few of the other states have have done
too but then a lot of states have done
anything and so we have the solution we
know how to solve the problem we just
get we just need to start implementing
it and I think the biggest thing that
can happen like the industry is growing
at forty fifty percent it will continue
to do really well but the biggest risk
too
a the industry right now it says the
thirty percent cash credit so that would
be a federal policy and it'll be ashamed
to see federal policy to get rid of it
completely it automatically expires or
this it goes down from thirty percent
down to ten percent and this is an
active change to keep it at thirty
percent and it won't a new says 2016 so
you would that would have to happen in
an election year so and that would be it
would be hard for people to get anything
done an election you're right yes sir so
the this is small probability that might
happen the end of this year and with the
oil export bill that may get momentum if
it gets momentum then as a trade
continue the the failed tax credit and
if that doesn't happen and the only
other option would be in the lame duck
end of next year and then if that
doesn't happen then you'll have a lapse
on the credit and it may be get it
through in February ish when they renew
how long do they renew for is there some
period of time but we have no idea so
before it was renewed for eight years a
fossil fuel doesn't have an expiration
just just in case do I know okay we had
a question right over here sharing with
us I have two questions first of all you
talked about the two different customers
the homeowners and utility and we
thought about enterprise with government
or different company agencies second
question you talked about the policies
that not my injury change such as tax on
carbon or incentive less incentive than
thirty percent connecting neighbors what
do you think is the most inhibitor like
what they need to change in terms of
government policy to move this board is
the next phase of expansion thanks uh
well fit was the fish fish low he wants
he wants the thirty percent it was at
this day yeah they pit I say what what
government policy yeah just whoa he said
well what government policy needs to
change to improve the the environment
it's or something like SolarCity
the solution tax credit and that s key
but the other player your question is
businesses as well so we known for a
residential business but we actually are
the largest commercial provider to we've
now just taking the leaderboard on it we
have about eight percent of of the other
market in our commercial rooftop
installation so I would do a lot of
commercial as well okay cold call
question right here front row texting
come on what's your question no she has
one come on here it is she ready go my
I'm not an engineering student but um I
guess my concern is that you have so you
have solar energy about what fraction
that is converted for my first section
percent funny so what's the efficiency
yes so another question is what percent
of the energy the solar energy coming
into the panel is converted to
electrical energy yeah call it depending
the modules but between fifteen and
twenty percent and we're the new panels
that's the twenty-two percent okay and
take eat right chef you can create
deserts essentially where you are
sending off really high energy because
we have this fear and I can have a lot
of environmental considerations that
might be hard to model a critic at this
point but I'm interested to know in
terms of like your concerns with the
lack of efficiency but then also the
underlying damages that you can see like
what what are you know but the heat
comes anywhere so one hundred percent
hits right now be nice action plan
beneath the plants yes so because you
create these factories right like there
was a example I read about in Arizona
and where they create these large solar
plant to question taxes
clergy yes then people had concerns were
that the surrounding environment because
obviously changed oh this is it this is
Sheetal is solar thermal so she's been
you've been reading about how the
tortoise has had to be moved from so
there's different ones so you have one
that reflects to a concentrator that
then heats up water um so that's that's
a different technology and still doesn't
could cause damage like I think just
emphasize at least it's um environment
impact but a lot less than a PowerPoint
okay the alternative is like girly
bulldoze Putin nasty nasty power plant
and that has a father gave back I mean
like the energy you produce is in
perfect square meter like 4,000 watts so
roughly speaking a pushka medium and you
do a thousand k just took push me to
what one kilowatt hour per square meter
is the hundreds in efficiency that's
just kind of hardly the math terms are
so if you doing that you're looking at
at tuna wats to turn what hours I'm
definitely doing another cold call you
yeah yeah you got a question come on
best questions come from a cold calls no
no look back what yeah you got a
question
many questions coming no did you hear
that you hear those questions well they
were the best questions so go ahead okay
go ahead take it with I work for a
software company solar software company
as a service called Satan I mean we do
sales and financial asset management and
ruin system design how do you see
technology we talked about when there's
going to be the self driving trucks and
factories how do you see technology
playing a role in years next 5-10 years
in your sales and asset management level
master like Vicki when we got started
and a good engineer would take a day to
do a design and now now they do 10
designs a day of course of software
automation so it's has a massive impact
and company is doing that I think not
just the design aspect if the full asset
management sales management gap so it
can have an impact okay we're going to
do do one more I'm disappointed in you
you in the back always centre-back it's
always the weirdest question come on my
name is idea from the Graduate School of
Business and my question is related to
energy storage so when you just let's
gigawatt factory that comes online is
that going to affect your business model
at all or not and second of all if any
of us are particularly interested in
energy storage should we be pursuing
that through Tesla or will there be room
it's all the city eventually or using it
depends on what you want to do in and
destroyed so first question is when the
factories at the gigafactory this 2 Giga
fresh one solar one battery but when the
battery gigafactory is up and running
what a perfect will that have in our
business and then the second one if
you're interested in getting into this
space in the battery space doing to get
so you go through solar studios to just
you go through through that Tesla so
first one as soon as the gigafactory is
up and running is actually help the
business tremendously and were even help
it before it gets the full capacity
because the cost of storage
coming down dramatically and as as that
factor ramps ramps up the cost comes
down we can start adding this to our
solar systems and really creating an
interesting product once again the
product is not necessary backup whether
that will be the primary the initial
product the biggest product is offering
great related services to the grid
that's the infrastructure as a service
part that is described in earlier in
terms of what you want to do it depends
on what your personalities if you're
looking at looking at applications for
deployment then Solar City is a good
place to go if you're looking at
engineering how you can prove the
chemistry of batteries then Tara is
definitely the better place so it's like
it depends on what you want to do all
right we're done we got the hook
you